celebrations on the streets of the
capital libreville Gabon free Gabon
liberated they chant crowds waving Palm
leaves in a sign of Victory hug Japanese
soldiers hours after they carried out
their Coop
we are so happy there is a sense of joy
we are waiting for this moment for so
long we suffered so much
professors champ the name of the man
leading the cup General
has been named as transition leader in
Gabon he is the head of the presidential
guard which pledged to protect president
Ali Bongo a close Aid to Bongo oligi put
Bongo under house arrest bringing to an
end The 56-year-long Bongo family
Dynasty alibongo once seen as strong and
Invincible appearing desperate and alone
appealing for help from his Palace where
he's being detained so I'm calling you
to make me noise
to make noise
to make noise really
I'm I'm thanking you a call that has
fallen on deaf ears following the
presidential election on Saturday the
vote was moored by Massive fraud says
the opposition Bongo ordered the
shutdown of the internet and banned
International observers and foreign
journalists from covering the election
when bongo's re-election was announced
on Wednesday morning the soldiers seized
power the newly formed Junta revoked the
election results arresting dozens of
electoral officials and accused them of
treason
we have decided to defend Peace by
putting an end to the current regime the
general elections of August 26 as well
as the truncated results are canceled
the borders are closed until further
notice all institutions of the Republic
are dissolved
the African Union has condemned the
latest coup in the region but the
gabonese people appear jubilant they
sing the national anthem and chant we
have chased Injustice and shame Gabon
has awoken to a new dawn Nicholas Hawk
Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera